you
I mean there is the stereotypical
chemist with you know the bad hair in
the pocket Philip I repent and just
stick you lating with great passionate
about his data we all know about that
it's an enduring image but it's one that
just doesn't really reflect reality
anymore
far from being a series of lone
Mavericks modern scientists rely heavily
on one another for progress science is
about collaboration initially with your
own students so I'm educating now the
next generation and they are awfully
talented people around me and all what
they need is a little bit of
encouragement they need to learn from me
the principles but they are much smarter
than I am
people come from all over the world
because they have the same interest and
how many people can actually say that
about their profession science is now an
enormous team effort crossing national
and political boundaries there's a
conservative Jew from Brooklyn a
Palestinian refugee from a camp in
Lebanon Spanish revolutionary an Italian
actor who wanted to fajn solve the
molecular basis of femininity that's the
magic of a laboratory it's an extended
and often rather eccentric family of
people with varied skills and diverse
interests getting the most out of life
in the lab relies on finding a place to
fit in many students get the impression
that you have to be very good in a whole
lot of domains and if you're going to be
a scientist math in particular that
really isn't true at all
the fact is most of science people don't
use much more mathematics than a grocery
store clerk
they really don't there are domains
where far from that I mean use the
highest level
they can find but but for most of it is
not the case working in a team where
everyone has complementary skills means
that labs can tackle much larger and
more interesting problems than a lone
researcher it's this hunger for new
knowledge that unites scientists
bringing them back to their labs day
after day it's the same thing that has
always driven research forward curiosity
just curiosity just by walking into the
street I mean there you can ask yourself
endless number of questions trees are
green why they are green why they are
not blue and you know the answer to each
of them is so awfully complex and so
awfully exciting that you must be
curious just to understand you're very
so-called
simple environment for some of us is
just the challenge of trying to
understand things it's some stunts
control sometimes people ask me well
what is it like it's like being in Stein
or something I think it's a lot more
like being Huckleberry Finn the
adventures you don't know what the
answers are but if it's intriguing if
it's worthwhile and it's fun then we do
it scientific exploration still holds
that thrill of discovery of something
new around the corner
it also makes it one of those rare
professions where your work can mesh
with your own passions but that does
tend to blur the boundaries between when
chemists are working and when they
aren't well it's not a nine-to-five job
it's more or less from the time one gets
up in the morning to the time one goes
to sleep late at night you get hooked on
these questions and you're thinking
about it all the time you think about it
in the shower in the morning you think
about it in the middle of the night you
think about it when you're riding your
bicycle and and you you just keep
turning over the possibilities I mean I
solve half of my problems you know
taking a shower walking down the street
or something you know yeah and so you
got to be thinking all the time about
about it and you got to be interesting
enough so that you're thinking about it
and and and that's really then when you
go in the laboratory or sit down it's a
lot of it's not already this curiosity
is something we're all born with from
the first moment we ask the question why
but that same curiosity can fall by the
wayside when confronted with a cryptic
patterns of the periodic table all the
intricacies of differential equations
science and math were the first things
encountered in school was it seemed to
be only one right answer and you were
expected to see how to get the answer by
some approved procedure and if you
didn't see this right away
of course you're likely to be alienated
and turn away from it and this is the
sad thing is how different that is that
real science the researcher is very
pleased to be confused because that
means there's something there that
probably other people don't understand
either and so gold and them thar hills
in that direction
unfortunately there's no getting away
from it trying to mine the truth out of
this confusion is no mean feat to be a
scientist and something like being a
musician I mean a real musician not just
the guy turns up the knob you know you
need to
master your instrument ADA master
literature and music and the culture
science is much like that but compared
with the musician the scientists can and
probably probably will play 99.9% of the
notes wrong then get one right but the
matter is you don't then get the right
one for a scientist there are no
boundaries one can grow it up in many
different directions and I've just found
that those opportunities teaching of
doing research of creating new materials
of having patents of starting companies
what an interesting life
you